hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen zu einem weiteren minecraft
video ich befinde mich hier gerade in
der lobby auf einem server und wir
spielen einfach mal runde jump
allerdings wird das ganze keine normale
youtuber runde jump league wo ich ein
bisschen gut bin weil ich bin ich gut
ich wollte nämlich ein real life format
von mir heute mal mit minecraft
verbinden und zwar habe ich ja oft so
dass immer einfach in welche fragen
stellen könnte in videoform über twitter
und da habe ich mir gedacht ja heute ist
freitag freitags kommt immer minecraft
übrigen sorry dass das wieder so spät
kommt aber ich habe der union musste
mich noch um sehr viel anderen scheiß
kümmern deswegen habe ich euch einfach
mal bei twitter gesagt dass sie mir
minecraft fragen stellen sollen also zu
minecraft und ich werde die dann
beantworten und nebenbei versuche ich
irgendwie noch zu zocken
ich glaube dass ich das alles nicht
hinkriegen werde eins und so ich kann
rüberspringen bei jump we geht es darum
dass ich quasi diese schnellstmöglich
diesen parcours hier irgendwie
wir fangen mit der ersten frage
2000 jahre später
das kommt nämlich dabei raus wenn ich
meinen zuschauern sagen die solche
fragen stellen die machen die sie machen
einfach nichts kann ich nicht einfach ja
gut lokal zum glück hat so toll geklappt
gibt es eigentlich in minecraft tomaten
das ist auch typische meine community
und zwar wird immer nach diesem blöden
tomaten satz gefragt ich weiß man sagt
ich blöd ich trinke selber auch immer
wenn ich fliege warum schaffe ich es
denn immer wenn ich fliege trainig
tomatensaft das liegt einfach daran weil
ich tomaten sagt maack und außerdem auch
tomatensaft ich glaube das hat sogar
eine positive wirkung beim fliegen
bezüglich druckausgleich auf den ohren
oder so um jetzt die gaddafis geschafft
und jetzt muss ich noch hinten kiste
eben schnell höher
so und jetzt haben wir schon mal ganz
gut zu sagen dieser tomatensaft running
gag eingeführt von stan ist ja immer
noch sehr aktuell auf meinem kanal war
ein ich irgendwo noch eine kiste gerade
oder habe ich mich da einfach verguckt
das wird ja so oft gebracht mit diesen
tomatensaft deswegen hat wie soll ich
ihm da drauf springen um die frage zu
beantworten ich denke es gibt in
minecraft leider keinem zumal die
wünsche wieder runter gefallen wie lange
spitze schon minecraft und meine zweite
frage ist warum bist du so schlecht
darin luca ich spiele minecraft
wahrscheinlich bereits schon seit wieso
kann ich da nicht drauf springen ich
spiele mal nach oben
es macht keinen sinn es geht nicht ich
spiele minecraft seit circa fünf jahren
und mache youtube seit fünf jahren also
ich habe ca
ich bin drauf seeger zeitgleich
angefangen wo ich dann auch als ich das
spiel entdeckt habe habe ich auch
relativ zeitnah angefangen mit
youtube-videos das war eigentlich ein
gleich laufender prozess irgendwie ich
habe glaube ich nur
einen monat oder so wirklich selber
minecraft gezockt ohne das ganze
aufzunehmen was ist eigentlich das kunst
du hast du jemals in minecraft gebaut
hast tomatensaft ich meine als ich die
frage gesehen habe bei twitter habe ich
mir schon gedacht okay wenn er so fragt
und sieht dann auch noch so lange zeit
lässt dann kommt entweder jetzt linken
fuß oder er beleidigt mich oder
tomatensaft und letzteres war dann der
fall ich war noch nie so der
singleplayer typ in minecraft wieso
schafft ich denn diesen sprung michael
das packt mich ja sowas von ab ich bin
ja die ganze zeit einfach nur gegen ist
es komplett egal jetzt ich bin drauf
golo karriere war und jetzt hier drauf
und auf die kiste und ja ich habe items
ich weiß nicht was das coolste was ich
je gebaut habe ich habe mal versucht
unser haus damals kommt schon oh geil
ich habe damals mal versucht unser haus
nachzubauen das fand ich schon sehr cool
für meine verhältnisse
das sei zwar letztendlich nachher
einfach außen hin geknotete stück code
aber der tag der vergeht wille und der
versuch war luca kannst mal minecraft
pocket edition auf einem server
aufnehmen ich hatte schon auf die idee
minecraft pocket edition aufzunehmen ich
hab's ja bisher glaube ich noch einmal
aufgenommen und dani zweimal auf 3 x 15
x aufgenommen ich habe keine ahnung ich
glaube ich habe es bisher ein oder zwei
mal aufgenommen ich weiß auch gar nicht
wo ich dahin laufen muss ich da oben hin
musst ich hätte bock das ganze nochmal
aufzunehmen das ist bei mir aber
irgendwie nur vollen vergessenheit
geraten das ist dieses spiel noch gibt
für für handy deswegen habe ich jetzt
lange zeit nicht gemacht ich habe auch
der zeit ein paar probleme mit meiner
elgato mit der ich ja die videos
aufnehmen und zwar habe ich das das
problem dass ich keinen ton mehr
aufnehmen kann das heißt wenn ihr
unbedingt wollte ja luca macht doch mal
hier
dings hier und bums hier dann wie nehme
ich damit tun auf weil ich kann nicht
mal ton einstellen das ist halt
irgendwie das problem ich hab da mein
handy angeschlossen und dass das ding
ist dann halt einfach so ist halt total
stumm und ich kann rechts nicht mehr ich
krieg nicht mehr in den ausschlag war
sie zeigt dabei wie ich das selbst ganz
mal anschließend das ist bei the way
keine werbung für elgato ich nehme damit
nur auf weil es die einzige möglichkeit
ist das ist die elgato und das habe ich
hier den den hdmi stecker und der hdmi
stecker geht auf diesen adapter und der
geht quasi an mein handy und die elgato
wird über usb an einen pc angeschlossen
also wenn ihr wisst woran das liegt dann
schreibt mir das gerne die kommentare
weil ich habe auch ultrabooks royal und
summe aufzunehmen zusammenfassend kann
ich also sagen wenn du dieses elgato
problem von mir gelöst wird wird auch
mal pocket edition hochgeladen werden
auf einem kanal auf die idee bin ich
tatsächlich noch nie gekommen sie hört
sich sehr nice an das ding ist
allerdings dass ich ja immer freitag als
minecraft acta gelegt habe und das
tatsächlich auch schon relativ lange
passend durchgezogen habe oder also
eigentlich haben wir immer freitags um
ein schaf video das ding ist nur dass
ich eh schon jeden freitag ein harter
überlegen bin so was gab es so in der
form noch nicht auf dem in minecraft
youtube deutschland und versuche mir
halt immer so mehr oder weniger neue
ideen einfach fakt ist mehr oder weniger
neue ideen einfallen zu lassen
zum beispiel dass jetzt gerade das video
fragen im bären gaming wären jump sieht
so dass das gab es so noch nicht da also
weiß ich nicht ich versuche halt jetzt
nicht so dass ich sage okay ich bin der
hundertste youtuber der master bilder
sorgt und dabei da muss ich hin deswegen
denke ich eher nicht weil wir dann
einfach ideen ausgehen würden weil ich
das ganze sehr um die frage zu
beantworten ich denke er nicht
außer ich hab mal eine kreative phase in
der dusche und kann machen wir über ganz
ganz viele sachen gedanken die ich
machen kann
nein verdammte scheiße was war erste
semester in minecraft einfach ich kenne
die genaue version nicht mehr das
einzige was ich noch weiß ist dass es
gerade der über fakt ist es geht schon
los es war gerade der übergang von alfa
zur beta also ich war ja fakt jetzt
werde ich hier auch noch verfolgt mandl
es war gerade den übergang von albert ii
was ist denn da packe war gerade der
übergang von alpha beta und ich musste
deswegen irgendwie mehr geld bezahlen
die leute bezahlen mussten die sich
damals das in dem alter noch gekauft
haben deswegen irgendwann dann luca
landgut dem pvp ich persönlich kann ich
da nicht richtig weiterhelfen allerdings
habe ich ja ein buch geschrieben buch
hilft da nicht weiter
spielst du minecraft lieber im
einzelspieler oder mehrspielermodus
teilweise was macht dir mehr spaß
ich spiele minecraft lieber im
mehrspielermodus finde aber auch den
einzelspielermodus teilweise recht
entspannt also mehr spieler zeit es gibt
keinen modus letztlich hektisches außer
vielleicht halten sie perfekt verstecken
ein paar sekunden später
ich werde das gewinnen weil ich jetzt
tot bin
kauft mein buch das ihr wie man gut wie
hier diese frage bildet jetzt auch schon
letzte frage für dieses video weil ich
ja die runde jetzt durch den tod beendet
habe und schlecht bin heil luca meine
frage lautet wenn du in minecraft einen
creeper sein könnte würdest du dann
genauso gerne leute abschlachten weg
wenn ich ein creeper wäre hätte ich
definitiv bock so die träume von einigen
minecraft spielern kaputt zu machen
indem ich die töte wenn sie gerade in
diamanten finden oder soll es doch da
hätte ich schon lust drauf das war es
mit diesem video meine lieben freunde
wenn es euch gefallen hat und ihr euch
denkt ja so was könnte man vielleicht
öfter mal anzeigt wenn man mit einem
daumen nach oben habt ihr allgemein
vielleicht ideen bezüglich so wie ich
dieses fragen formats ein bisschen
ausbauen könnte also das ist nicht meine
mir macht das ultra viel spaß dass ihr
mir videos zusendet von irgendwas und
ich darauf reagieren oder antworte oder
so was in die richtung denn je der ideen
habt das musste ich in kombination mit
minecraft sein das kann auch einfach so
riel als sein anschreiben das gerne in
die kommentare was ihr da gern sehen
würde weil mir das am meisten spaß macht
jetzt auf youtube und wir sehen uns dann
vielleicht in einem nächsten video
wieder haut rein kommt man das schnell